Таски закрываем, определяем пуши, видите на
пора нос?
Вы расширяем в зоне пуба.
И дальше на носу.
В следующем точке щеках пор уже инили.
Минча становится, что такое комбинирован
ное кожа.
Когда несколько два, два, два, два типа кожи.
Когда перемешанное, тип кожа называется
комбинированное.
На подворотке тоже.
Вот небольшие прорывы.
Нашие прорывы.
Есть прорывы, что вы давливаете с носа?
Да.
И как ты долго-то продолжаешься?
Ой, давно.
Она не часто.
Замечаем, что каждый раз вы давливаете, но
пора больше становится.
Да, вот эта самая прорывочка.
О порах, как вы думаете, что у вас порах?
Сольный жир.
Да, наверное, грязька.
Уча всего идеальны варианты, либо выходить
на чистку.
Но не так часто, да?
Есть другой варианты.
Если у вас идеальный, на машинах вот таких
вот пор, в мире, да?
Вот мне должно быть.
Вот жиру, когда вы думаете, делим умывание
на ха баха кислотами.
Когда вы думаете, вот эти пора растворяется
.
Это утром вечером.
На линдинском уровне должна выходить на р
уши.
Для чего делаете риши?
Для того, чтобы очистить именно жир в порах.
Для того, чтобы все полезные компоненты тон
нера в сыварах, отец, альмов, что пропиталь
ность.
А нужно хорошо очистить кожу.
Если возьмите кубик, пенка, деликарную, да?
Порах пора только будет забиваться, вы
будете выдавливать.
Еще в обычных лет, да?
Вот выдавливание.
Мы замечать, что у нас немножко врасно сним
аются этих участков.
Потом, там, в 30-30, у вас так нужно какое-то.
Как то, что все полупаются.
И только в данальном племном противе зак
рывает.
То есть, вы этого делаете лучше не надо.
Идеальное уходит о геоблемывании.
Вашем случае, да?
Вот по типу кое-же комбинирована тип кое-же.
Нужно будет геоблемывание с ха баха кислот
ами.
Тоннер.
Глажняющий.
Да, либо же с витамином ц.
И крем, кое-же уважняющий.
Испертик.
Обязательно так голову поверните.
Теперь по состоянию кое-же.
По состоянию кое-же, что вас беспокоит.
Вообще, вот, загорадный человек, прям следы
от очков, у меня стали.
Вот, особенно вот эта зона, пигменты, эти
появляются пятна.
Пигментация здесь есть.
Отбравяем.
Вот еще подбравяем.
Здесь пигментные пятна.
Если так.
Испефленно поршитесь?
Нет.
Смотрите у мамы.
У нее все есть.
Берите вот ее уход.
Например, я не знаю ели.
Пен, скорее всего, вам нужно быть геем.
У нее уложения сенса есть.
СПF крем.
Берите у нее все.
А на все вам, прям, подойдет.
Только умывание.
Нужно будет другое.
Пигментация.
Видите, у вас тут ярко выраженное.
Если ее свое временно не устранять, так же
будете загорать.
Вот еще ярко выраженное.
Вот такая полоска будет.
У нее много скол.
Смотрите на глазах.
Вы их участок надо мазать.
Да, вот и сплю.
СПF вообще все-таки тоже.
А для того, чтобы ее вывести,
хотя бы одну процедуру сделала, то он будет
пилинг.
Растительный гонзарас, он вас выведется.
На сегодня мы с вами сделаем честь.
Отравма честь.
Не даже не честь.
Сегодня давайте сделаем харбоксперапи.
Она также будет осетлять пигментацию.
Хотя бы.
Да, и такой хороший обижирывающий эффект
будет.
И сейчас вот сделаем процедуру по состояни
ю кожанин.
Потому, как вот первый раз пришли на честь.
Чтобы у вас лишний раз не прозмировать.
Не начинать выдавливать что-то с носом.
Чтобы потом возвращения от чести появилось
.
На лет этот раз мы сделаем вам без нюцени.
Беретализация.
Это корбокстерапи, называются потупом.
На лице им нас нет декоративной осметики.
А сейчас восемь, который дедливный вонит.
Как овостит кожа комбинированный.
И сейчас данный возьму пенку.
Будет телекарное чещение.
Соответственно, все полезные компоненты.
И сможем пропитать кожу.
Поэтому я беру обязательно дедливный воним
.
На количестве листя.
Экстора дедевая.
Можете спинить.
Круппа.
И сразу на лице.
Создавительные домования есть хаба хаби с
лунками,
которые очень хорошо расшепляют под кожан
ым жиром втура.
Когда лицо наути.
Не в коем случае гедливому воним предфитир
ать не нужно.
Идет химическое реакция.
Когда вы тактируйте и намесвады.
Вспенивайте лице гедливому воним.
Вообще, зачем нужен гедливому воним?
Можно где пенка, можно же ее было.
А задача гедливому воним.
Садежим на впорах.
Соснабий сахаба хаби с лунками.
Это органические фруктовые молочные кисл
оты,
которые очень хорошо расшепляют жир.
Кожны сало.
Пенка с этим не справляется.
У нее на бродилихатное течение пенка предв
езначено.
И недостаточное течение.
Потом со временем будете замечать
воспаления, проще будет появляться.
Хорошо, как спениваем.
Выцом.
Да, это избегает хуже вокруг вас.
Соснабий.
Вот смотрите.
Это пенка.
Вы будете мубать ваша лицо.
Вы будете даже в праздницу чувствовать
зависимости от времени.
Да, до 8 летнее время у вас гедливому воним.
Это будет плохо пениться.
А в зимнее время, либо в России, тогда в
центральной отоплении.
На вашей хуже сколько появляется.
Она будет очень серия пениться.
Это зависит от того, насколько восхоже жирн
ется.
Летом обычно жирнется.
И все очень плохо пенится.
Думается, пенится.
Ктижка много жира.
И пенка не так активно проявляется.
Это, знаете, для того, чтобы понимали.
Тарелка будет жирная.
Другая будет не очень.
Если бы ее, например, в летнее время, она
будет, что какую-то жирню еду сели,
может их даже зимнее время.
Жирнее все лицо жирнится.
Потом возьмете пенка и будете мыть.
Чистая тарелка, как слегка, загрязненный т
арелик, будет очень сильная пенится.
А вот грязный тарелка, вам нужно будет
больше моющегося.
Это для того, чтобы ее почистить, то же
самое с лицом.
Говорят, почему пенка и вельно-мывание в
разные время по-разному себя ведет.
Это про состояние нашего кожа.
В зависимости от того, что мы употребляем
внутрь.
Черные точки, видите, за счет того, что в
своей весе хабахать.
Фрутовый молочный кислот, который очень
хорошо повышает темунити.
И черные точки даже у вас уже освет выявить.
Они не очистились, но мы ставим уже светлее.
До счета уже потолит.
Затемнение очистилось.
Самое письмо, кожная сала, она же белого
цвета.
Она вот контактирует с кислородом, когда
поднимается выше.
Она начинает тиметь чернеественную.
Как с салой же подсыхает?
На какой-то воздухе.
То же самое.
Карпоксетеропием в коробке находится 5 наб
оров на 5 применений.
Обычные маски применять не в случае нельзя.
У нее есть своя маска пропитана улики сломг
азом.
Это активатор.
Это сам активатор.
На одно применение.
И в комплекте у него идет маска.
Маска находится на дне коробки.
Он не потеряет ноги, когда покупает, думать,
что мы туда ее не положили.
Сейчас мы будем делать коробоксетеропием.
Я возьму ее так, что кожа там пинили.
Я возьму домер антибактериальный.
Одну парню.
Можно взять отбиливающий тонн.
Как у нас есть кожа комбинированная.
Это я взяла антибактериальный тонн.
Можно взять асфетляющий отбиливающий тонн.
Это активатор.
В первую очередь вывести кожи токсины.
В любом случае, тогда мы потребляем размыли
руем.
Не важно.
В любом случае у нас на кожи в корах накап
ливаются токсины.
Капливаются токсины.
Задача коробоксетеропием вывести токсины
кожи.
Вывести кожи токсины кожи в корах накаплив
аются токсины кожи в корах накапливаются т
оксины кожи.
В любом случае у нас на кожи в корах накап
ливаются токсины кожи в корах накаплив
аются токсины.
Вывести кожи токсины кожи в корах накаплив
аются токсины кожи в корах накапливаются т
оксины кожи в корах накапливаются токсины
кожи в корах накапливаются токсины кожи.
Вывести кожи токсины кожи в корах накаплив
аются токсины кожи в корах накапливаются т
оксины кожи в корах накапливаются токсины
кожи.
Вывести кожи токсины кожи в корах накаплив
аются токсины кожи в корах накапливаются т
оксины кожи в корах накапливаются токсины
кожи в корах накапливаются токсины кожи в
корах накапливаются токсины кожи в корах
накапливаются токсины кожи в корах накап
ливаются токсины кожи в корах накаплив
аются токсины кожи.
лицо пощипывает, то лучше всего сделать, эм
икратоков, уетерапии, либо же какой-нибудь
успокаивающую процедуру, например, там нан
ести ампул с панданулом, либо же ампулу с
регинировающими
компонентами, и святленей кидермашек, это о
что покоже восстановилось, чтобы для того,
чтобы
восстановить эпидермис, когда пациент, как
говорит после нанесения, у первого этапа,
что
кожа пощипывает, и теперь посипнала о том,
что поврежденный эпидермис в 4 раз, и в 5 раз.
Опять цене вам нужно будет в основной виде
эпидермис, причинил вот этих пощипований,
да, повреждения эпидермиса могут быть неп
равильный ход, в большинстве случаят неправ
ильный
уход, у кого, например, комбинированное жир
нее тип кожи, из-за тренда на уход в
форейский ход, либо же самостоятельный наз
начение разных профессиональных линей,
приводит к тому,
что даже элементартное отчение кожа моего,
приводит к тому, что кожа у нас раздраж
ается,
эпидермис повреждается, по этому лепции по
структуре, потому что как вы косметологи,
вы прям на
изусь должны знать строение кожи и функции
код, теперь в очереди кожа на что дело защищ
ает, если
ваш пациент таким, то, образом, добровольно
самостоятельно носит какие-то агрессивные
средства и
повреждает эпидермис, это первое защитение
, защиты кожи повреждён тогда, первое время
раздражение,
покраснение ладно, потом со временем появ
ляется какие-то хаинусские заболевания,
а легийские реакции, а какие-то космет
ические средства, это первое очередь из-за
повреждения эпидермиса.
Наша задача - остановите ее, а потом уже
начинайте носить какие-то, точнее, провод
ить какие-то процедуры,
первую очередь нужно восстановить эпидерм
ис, снять разрешение. Для этого очень хорошо
помогает аппаратную
процедуру микротоки, либо же даже элемент
арно, регенерирующего маску на несёте, охл
аждебную ночь,
быстро осуновлено эпидермис, почти что-
нибудь чувствуете, мы бы стекрыли в носу
чуть-чуть по щековыми, да?
Есть привычка, скребает либо же механизки
повреждает с носа, почему именно крыльях
носа, если посмотреть
визуально, да, вот весь вас есть покрасн
ение и сосуды, это уже поврежденные сосуды,
которые
про низко расположены поверхности кожи, и
кожи там очень тонкая, поэтому мы визуально
видите вот эти расосуды, и быстро проникает
, так теми-то оппоненты под конже, и вы
чувствуете это
разрушение, а теперь стебящая-то, поэтому
скорбов всегда реплируем, ну сам карбов
всегда
репейный маск, это не простая маска, она
проситально углекистая глазом, после охно
несения
активатора она, смотрите, так вообще
работает, еще раз повторяем, когда вы
первый слой наносите на кожи,
она выступает как компонент, который вывод
ит из кожи все загрязнение, так сильно, она
быть ядебает из кожи спор всю грязь, а потом
когда вы нанесем вот эту вот маску,
идет имичесто авиация, кожи начинают внабж
ать кислородом, и все все грязь начинают р
астворяться,
все грязи живут, они все что на столице на
столице, это просто мастера, видите мастера
, она сама
посипит ввертая, сейчас нанесу на лицо, за
ранее нужно полопоценку предобретить в том
,
что будет небольшой почти пованей, у кого-
то сильнее, а почти пованей, у кого я подяну
сь в германине,
какие-то грожные заболевания, в карбот-стер
пе можно объявить применение, только у них
будет болевые,
ощущения не сильнее, когда здоровая кожа
небольшой почти пованей, нормально, в дан
ном случае, наша
пациенте будет, скорее всего, сильнее всего
, посиповать только зоны на крупнейности,
мы ее наносим, да и прижимая, вот посипа
разрешал,
то есть, как у этой иголочке такое, как у
этой иголочке,
старайтесь прижимать, руками лицом на пром
ахимом, прижимаем, коросном жарится кислор
одам, да и очищение,
таким образом у нас максимальное очищение,
все поры, в которой у нас закупоренные, они
все полностью
расщипляются, и после карбоксетерпийни, да,
все активные компоненты, можно даже
сделать кроксонные
мизетерпии, микротокки, насыть и кожу полез
ными компонентами, да, это нецензный, не
будете наносить,
нам будут колгубку, впитывать результат,
будет 10 раз лучше, чем просто так именно на
носить,
в летнее время особенно актуальным, в лет
нее время многие боятся делать механичес
кую
чиску, на самом деле это правильно, или это
не рекомендуются делать механическую
чиску, потому что после механического повр
еждения могут остаться пидментные пяты,
потому что
яркое солнце, а карбоксетерпия получается
без механического повреждения, будет кожу
очищать,
и в то же время насыщает кожу кислородным,
что здоровый свет пицца, многие жалуются,
что, например, у меня
туской свет лица, неровный тон кожей, да,
вот эта процедура идеально подходит как
экспресс-процедура,
после него он должен сразу брать на юбилей,
с равной и снимой кияж, декоративную космит
ку, и на
следующий день в стейне может быть только
еще лучше, может быть более матовое, жене
близко уже
перестанем беспокоить, ну то то и парен
тогда вы не начнете, то есть у вас пациенты,
не начнете
заведать, да, там вредный едой, в любом
случае у нас кожа нет, не пластиковая, наф
ункционирует, у нее есть
своя жизнь идеятельность, она убудет все
таксиные через поры, она дышит обменные
процессы идут, ежедневные,
ежедневные, ежедневные, ежеминутно, ежесек
уютно даже,
На севере мис выкопываете на скупете?
Он предназначен для второго дарота с этим.
Он очень хорошая функция обжиривающая и ед
ет.
Он целый, не о функции очень хорошая есть.
Это очень хорошая функция обжиривающая и
едет.
Добавляем эту функцию обжиривающая и едет.
Редактор субтитров А.Семкин Корректор А.Е
горова